un paso más hacia la paz en Etiopía el
sábado las fuerzas Rebeldes de la región
del tigre y el gobierno de Etiopía
firmaron un acuerdo que concretes a las
etapas de la implementación de la paz
que fue pactada el 3 de noviembre en
Sudáfrica
nos dedicaremos plenamente a aplicar el
acuerdo de pretoria y esta declaración
ambas partes se comprometieron a
permitir la llegada de la muy esperada
ayuda humanitaria al tigre y la
protección de los civiles el acuerdo
debe tener efecto inmediato y también
previa el desarme de los Rebeldes
me alienta el hecho de que ambas partes
reconozcan la necesidad de que el pueblo
de Etiopía venga de donde venga necesita
hoy asistencia humanitaria necesita
alimentos necesita medicinas necesita
que se reanuden los servicios el tigre
fue devastado por dos años de guerra
Durante los cuales la región fue aislada
por los mi etíopes el conflicto mató al
menos 100.000 personas y desplazó a
millones además cientos de miles están
al borde de la hombruna en la región
hemos sufrido una miseria incalculable
Durante los dos últimos años y seguimos
sufriendo el compromiso que asumimos hoy
es con la esperanza y las expectativas
de que el sufrimiento de nuestro pueblo
llegue a su fin y pronto
sin embargo la paz sigue siendo frágil y
ambas partes tendrán que comprometerse
en la rendición de cuentas además
eritrea el vecino de Etiopía involucrado
en el conflicto al lado del Gobierno
Federal no ha tomado parte en las
negociaciones